that's like us don't get the girl
well that's not true anymore now that
Oliver and Felicity are adorably in love
arrow star Emily BETT Rickards is
weighing in on Barry's love life and
which central city girl should really be
with the fastest man alive I think it's
really great for Barry to see that like
oh you can get the girl and like well
maybe that could be possible for him in
the future so I take it that Felicity
has various blessing to do with Oliver
yeah and it makes it it makes it really
cool for them to be friends too because
it kind of takes off that edge a little
bit of like you know they never they
never really talked about their what
their relationship was it just didn't I
mean obviously they had chemistry and
they're great friends and they're very
both scientific and their minds work a
lot of like but that that passion that
love is obviously what Felicity and
Oliver have and that's how our
relationships move and work in real life
so that's how it works then what is
wrong with us we are perfectly perfect
for each other
yeah we're sitting here pining for
people we can't have Barry has chemistry
with every single girl that comes into
this house right now like literally like
right now there are three different
girls that the fans each desperately
want him to be with what's the iris okay
Caitlin right and patty spivot he's
brand-new I heard she's like she's
fantastic but I got it now who do you
think that Felicity would be rooting for
Barry to be with I don't know I guess
like Caitlin's got a little bit of
baggage right now but she's good friends
with Caitlin yeah I think that good she
doesn't know iris it's like very well at
all like they've been on a couple unit
but Kaylin her like bone friends so I
would think that and I think she'd
probably like patty
if she were to cross paths Fleur I hear
she's amazing like the list he hears
that she's great yeah I feel like that
would be something that would make her
want to be friends with patty in that
context
you